et puis c'est aussi du sport surtout à
83 ans rencontre avec Germain Elbert une
Loire échérienne adepte du saut en
parachute a lien entre l'ULM
l'hélicoptère et le saut en parachute
donc elle a tranché c'est le saut
qu'elle préfère elle en avait déjà trois
à son actif il lui en fallait un 4e
histoire de faire encore le plein de
sensation forte fostine luno était
présente pour ce Saud dans le vide à
l'aéroport de Blois
lebreuil comme ceci il y a un Cambri
jamb Jérôme donne les consignes avant le
grand saut aujourd'hui le moniteur va se
jeter dans le vide avec une élève qu'il
connait bien Germain 83 ans on évite les
looping mais bon après c'est en fonction
de c'est en fonction de l'état de forme
de Germain on
peut j'ai marché à qu PES ouais donc
donc voilà on évite les looping avec
Germain seule j'ai plus rien à faire il
faut dire que l'équipement germ connaît
puisqu'elle revient tenter l'expérience
pour la 4e fois depuis ses 80 ans un
rêve vieux de plusieurs années qu'elle a
enfin réalisé sans aucune appréhension
même la première fois j'ai pas eu peur
hein même la première fois j'ai pas eu
peur elle me dit ce qu'il faut faire
elle me dit ce qu'il faut faire
maintenant c'est incroyable on avait
offert à mon grand-père un tour d'avion
et après il y avait des son parachute et
c'est la suite de ça ça fait 50 ans la
suite de ça que j'ai eu envie de le
faire et un jour j'ai une amie son frère
à son avion ici je lui dis ça m dit
attends je téléphone à mon frère pour
voir et tout bon dit si si si faut venir
je connais bien les gars et tout bon
c'est parti comme ça dernière étape
montter dans l'avion pour le
[Musique]
décollage après une vingtaine de minutes
de vol pour prendre de l'altitude c'est
parti Germain et Jérôme sautent à 3000 m
au-dessus du vide pour 30 secondes de
chute libre à 200 km/h avant d'ouvrir le
parachute
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bon toujours le même plaisir alors sans
regret et ben je suis ravi d'avoir
partagé ce so avec toi toujours aussi
agréable c'est vrai queon on se marre
bien on rigole bien c'est
et comme d'habitude celle qui a aussi
testé l'ULM et l'hélicoptère en
redemande elle se laisse tenter cette
fois-ci par un tour en Stampe ce petit
avion biplan un nouveau baptême de l'air
à 83 ans car il n'y a pas d'âge pour
devenir accro aux sensations forte au
revoir à bientôt on vous regardera la
[Musique]
télé y